لذلك كجزء من مطاردتنا للحصول على إجابات حقًا ،
لقد قيل لنا إنه
لم يعد مسموحًا للمسؤولين هنا
بالتحدث علنًا عن هذه القضية
ولم يُسمح لهم بالإجابة على أسئلتنا
لأن مكتب الداعية أصبح الآن جزءًا من
هذا التحقيق وقد تم هنا
أخبرتهم ألا يتحدثوا إلينا ، فقالت
إحالتهم إلينا ، لذلك ذهبنا إلى
مكتبها اليوم لطرح أسئلتها ،
فهناك الكثير من المعلومات التي يجب
أن تخرج
سيدتي
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] ولذا يمكنك أن ترى هناك أندرسون
كانت  برفقة نائب العمدة
هناك في سيارتها ثم
غادرت ببساطة لم ترغب في الإجابة على أي
أسئلة قالت إنها لم يكن لديها تعليق في
وقت ما عندما تحدثنا إليها داخل
المبنى ولكن مرة أخرى هذا جزء
من الطريقة التي هم بها  تعمل الآن
رافضة الإجابة على أي من أسئلتنا